it's all or nothing for Greece but Prime
Minister Alexis tsipras is holding his
confidence stance I'm here ready for
another scam remise we owe that to the
peoples of Europe who wants europe
united not divided we can reach an
agreement tonight if all parties wanted
and greek Finance Minister Euclid
Sokolow dose is all smiles as well
despite the fact that his European
colleagues seem no closer to a deal the
eurozone is split on whether or not to
grant a bailout France argues yes
Finland is deeply opposed but the talks
continue no no one is blocking a deal we
are all constructively trying to find a
solution in a very difficult situation
what we are saying is that the
conditionality that has been presented
by the Greeks is simply not enough if
the Greek government commits to
implement and vote now without delay
strong reforms in the short term that
there is the basis for the opening of
negotiations of a program which has been
requested by this government and that
would be a third multi-billion euro aid
package lasting three years it would be
so expensive that the German Finance
Minister Wolfgang Schauble has instead
proposed a temporary grexit for at least
five years time for Athens to completely
restructure its debt or he says Greeks
must commit too much stronger austerity
measures than those proposed by Athens
yeah I'm gets me female you're looking
at shortfalls and Finance which exceed
anything we've seen in the past [ __ ] and
I pacific-12 so will new negotiations
seal a deal or not EU leaders cancelled
an EU summit scheduled for today leaving
the eurozone leaders to decide the fate
of Greece and the outcome is not just
about monetary amounts but also about
trust